hi everyone
welcome to our talk in this session
we'll show you how you can develop
applications in ides
using cloud code if you're deploying to
cloud run
my name is balian potto i'm a software
engineer at google
and i was the lead for the project
delivering the cloud-run experience
for cloud code and i'm matt i'm also an
engineer at google on the cloud code
team
before we jump into the ids for those
who are unfamiliar with cloud drone
let's see briefly what cloud run
actually is
cloudrun enables you to run stateless
containers
in a fully managed environment these
stateless container instances
are spun up when the application
endpoint is triggered on demand
if the application receives no requests
however
these instances scale back down to zero
depending on what your preference is you
have two flavors of cloudron that you
can work with
the fully managed environment is a
pay-as-you-go service
with zero need for managing any kind of
infrastructure meaning
no servers no clusters are required
however
it is a cloud only option cloud run for
ntos runs cloud from workloads on gk
clusters
enabling customers to run workloads
wherever enthus can run
for example in your data center on
premises
clabron is typically used to run web
applications
public apis or backends for mobile apps
you can choose to make these stateless
containers however
private as well as part of a larger
application for example
a microservice or executing tasks based
on
events or part of your etl pipeline this
all sounds great in theory
however it is actually easier to show
what cloudone is than explaining it so
let's deploy
a sample app using the cloud console and
the command line
to deploy an application to cloud run
from my browser
i'm going to use google cloud console
let's choose the cloud run tab
create service button my choice of
deployment platform is going to be
the fully managed cloud run service and
i'm going to deploy to
us central one region the service name
is
something simple
i am going to let anybody access this
application is going to be public
and the application i'm going to use a
prepared pre-built application that is
just a simple
web app listening on port 8080
and that's it i'm just going to hit
create and
cloud run will deploy my application
so anytime i hit the endpoint
the response is going to be coming from
an instance that was spun up on demand
and there it is so let's do something
similar on the command line
from starting from uh code so
i have a simple go application
that uses a docker file to build an
image out of it
so let's build it
and i am going to push it
as well docker push
to this gcr google cloud container
registry
url in my project so that gcloud
run deploy
can deploy it i'm going to go through a
very similar set of choices
so the fully managed platform is my
choice of deployment platform
service name is going to be last name
and go up one two three
and u.s central going to be the region
and my application is going to be yes
public
gcloud does the same thing that cloud
console did
it deploys it asks cloudrun to deploy
this
uh container image so when i hit this
end point
my new instance is gonna respond
with hello world that was great
isn't cloudron just awesome as soon as
you have a container you can just
run it in the cloud fantastic
but then the questions come how do we
get to that container
also do i always need to use the command
line or the browser
luckily that is exactly what we're gonna
talk about here
so let's have a look at the agenda we
covered what cloud run is
next matt will explain what cloud code
is
and then we'll show you a bunch of demos
starting from the ids where we will
deploy
from vs code and we'll develop a more
complex application
in intellij onto umat
thanks valent cloud run is great but
developing for it can be challenging
without the right tools
for example if you're new to cloud run
getting started might seem a little
intimidating
it can be difficult to know how to build
a container
once your application is containerized
for cloud run developing and debugging
it locally
is not as straightforward as it would be
with a non-containerized application
finally there are many tools to assist
with cloud run but it would be nice not
to have to constantly context switch
between the cli
web browser and editor this is where
cloud code comes in
cloud code is a set of tools for
intellij and visual studio code
that helps you write cloud native
applications including applications for
cloud run
cloud code comes integrated with sample
projects in java
go python and node.js to help you get
started setting up your cloud run
application
cloud code can help you containerize
your existing application and will
simulate the cloud run environment
locally
this lets you develop your app in an
environment that is very close to
production
while letting you use your ide to do
things like set breakpoints and debug
once you're ready to deploy cloud code
makes that easy too
by hooking into the ide's existing
deployment mechanisms
and you can view previous deployments in
the cloud run explorer
cloud code is available for free for
visual studio code and the jetbrains
ides from the respective plugin
marketplaces
we have public issue trackers on github
and would love to hear if you have any
feedback after trying it out
now on to the fun stuff balance is going
to show you how to get started with
cloud code for vs code
remember when i asked how you can deploy
an app from the ide without the use of
the browser or the command line well
let's see our first demo
from the ide i have vs code installed
and matt has intellij so i'm going to
show a vs code based demo first
in this demo we'll see how you can
create a sample application and deploy
it to cloud run
using cloud code for visual studio code
after you install the extension from the
vs code marketplace
you can confirm that it is activated by
seeing a cloud
code button in the status bar
let's start by creating a new sample
application first i will click on the
cloud good button
to bring up the available commands then
hit new application
and cloud run application the available
languages for sample applications
are java python node.js golang and
c-sharp
i will create my sample application
written and go
my application is created now it is a
simple web application
that listens on port 8080 has a docker
file
has a simple go file and a test file
and in the readme we can see that the
next step
is to open the command palette and run
the cloud good deployment command so
let's do that
i'm going to enter cloud code deploy
there it is
cloud code recognizes that i'm logged
into gcp with my account using gcloud
it automatically selects the project
that i set as the default one
let's walk through the options to deploy
most of these should be very familiar
from the cloud console options that i
demoed earlier
let's start with the service settings
cloud code allows me to create a new
revision
of an existing service or to create a
new service
i will create a new service and name it
hello next on
air
wealth as i explained
we have the two flavors of the
deployment platform for for cloud run
the fully managed and cloud one for
enthus
i am going to deploy to fully managed
using the us central one
region i'm going to keep my application
public
and the revision settings show
the opportunity for setting some
advanced settings for my application
including the container image url where
the application is going to be pushed up
to and other advanced
options the build settings
are something that is different from the
cloud console settings this is
what sets up how the application is
going to be
built into a docker image
cloud code recognizes that my
application can be built using docker
or build packs i'm going to choose
buildbacks because that's the
cooler option because i don't have to
write a single line of docker file
code or know what docker is it just
builds my application into a docker
image
so let's hit deploy
as my application builds and deploys
i should be able to see
after it succeeds that
my new service should show up between my
my projects
cloud code provides a cloud run panel
that has a cloud run explorer
which as we see shows the
list of services in my project hello
nexon air world
my newly created service just showed up
it has we can see in the properties
panel that it has the service name hello
next in their world
it has a url where it's deployed u.s
central
region as expected and it has one
serving revision
which has 100 of the traffic allocated
to it
i can check the logs
for this revision and by right clicking
on the service
i can also open the url for my
application
and there it is before we continue i
wanted to add two more notes
local development features are going to
be released later in august
and they will be available in both vs
code and intellij
i did not demo them because we didn't
have time for it here
however matt will show you inside
intellij
the local development features the
second note
is about the artifact registry while we
are showing
google container registry in our demos i
recommend you
to check out google artifact registry
which is currently in beta
and it will provide the next generation
of features for storing
amongst other artifacts docker
containers as well
thanks balant next i'll be showing you
how you can do some local development
using cloud code for intelligent
in this next demo i'm going to walk
through how we can update an existing
cloud run application to talk to an
external database
we'll then iterate on some changes debug
it and finally deploy it back to cloud
run
here is an application currently
deployed to cloud run that lets you vote
on your preferred indentation
preferences
tabs or spaces as you can see here this
app keeps a running count of votes for
tabs and spaces
and shows recent votes down at the
bottom here
each time i vote my vote is recorded and
the recent vote section is updated
now i'll switch to cloud code for
intellij where we can examine the code
it's a nodejs express app and the bulk
of it is implemented in this
server.js file now as you can see here
there are two main route handlers
one for handling the get http request
and one for handling the post http
request
so in the get request handler we get the
recent votes
we get the counts for the number of
votes for tabs and spaces
we do some calculations to determine
what text to display on the screen
and then we render it in the post
request handler
we receive an incoming vote and then we
use this cast vote method to record the
incoming vote
i'll step into this cast vote cast vote
method where it simply takes the vote
and persists it to our in-memory votes
array
so here is what the current architecture
looks like
so there's a problem with this as you
can see here the way we implemented our
data store is in memory
inside the container and this is a
problem because cloud run is designed to
work with stateless ephemeral containers
so when cloud runs scales down to zero
or scales up
this data will be lost we can avoid this
data loss and make
our container stateless by moving our
data store out of the container and by
having our container talk to an external
database
so let's try to implement this with
cloud sql which is gcp's managed
sql database here is what our desired
architecture will look like
i've gone ahead and created that votes
table the cloud console
and updated the code to talk to that
database you can see that i replaced the
methods here with ones that execute sql
queries
for full details on the changes i made
check out the code in the github repo
linked in the slides
so we just made a lot of changes and i
could push this directly to cloudrent to
see if it works
but i don't want to do that normally i'd
want to test my changes out locally
first before deploying to production
cloud code lets me do that by providing
a simulated cloud run local development
environment to test on so let's try that
out using the cloud run
run locally run configuration i have one
set up here that i'll quickly run
through
i've named it run locally and configured
it to build my application using the
docker builder since there is a docker
file present in my project
cloud code has also detected that my
project is buildable using build packs
which is a container building technology
that will automatically containerize my
application without the need for a
docker file
but since we have a docker file we can
just stick with that in the advanced
revision settings here i've also
configured my application with the
environment variables
sql connection string and service
account required to talk to the cloud
sql database
full details on these are also provided
in the link to github repository
so let's try it out clicking play here
will start the cloud code simulated
cloud run environment
internally cloud code is using tools
like scaffold and minicube to build
containerize and run my application in a
local kubernetes cluster behind the
scenes
alright it looks like it was able to run
my app we can launch it by going to the
event log here and clicking this link
and here's my app running locally you
can see it's running on localhost
in the cloud run simulated environment i
can cast votes and it looks like they're
properly persisted
but let's just double check to make sure
and i can do that by going back to my
terminal
and checking to see if they're actually
saved to cloud sql
so i'm going to quickly write a sql
query
to verify this and yep it looks like the
votes i cast were properly saved in the
votes table
so that's great to recap cloud code
helped me containerize and run my
application in a simulated cloud run
environment so that i could test my
application locally before deploying to
cloud run
when i'm developing a cloud run app i
want quick feedback loops
i want to make changes and see those
changes reflected quickly so that i can
iterate
and i don't want to have to manually
build an image and redeploy to cloud run
each time i want to test my application
out
fortunately cloud code makes that easy
for me by automatically building and
redeploying my app to a local simulated
cloud run environment when it detects
source changes so let's see that in
action
let's say i want to add some extra
exclamation points to the end of this
text
i'll go to my ide and add some
exclamation points
when i hit save cloud code detects the
change and automatically rebuilds and
redeploys my container
this keeps the inner development loop
tight so that i can quickly iterate
alright so now if i go back to my app
and refresh the page
my change is reflected there notice how
i didn't need to craft and run multiple
docker commands in order to redeploy my
changes since cloud code
automatically took care of that for me
let's see how cloud code helps me debug
my cloud run application
normally debugging code running inside
containers can be tricky
there are source mappings to configure
and ports to forward and each language
handles it a bit differently
cloud code takes care of all of this for
me by utilizing scaffold debugging
capabilities under the hood
my application has a bug that i've
planted if spaces start winning their
win count goes negative
so cloud code lets me debug this using
all the debugging tools that i'm used to
i don't have to modify my docker file to
include debugging utilities or configure
ports
cloud code does it for me i can set a
breakpoint
and then run my application in debug
mode
so right now cloud code is configuring
my container to be debuggable
it also detected the appropriate path
mapping for me to set up
now that the debugger is attached if i
reload the page
the breakpoint is hit and i can step
through
so i'll step through that things look
right
and here's where that negative one came
from diff
is negative one and it looks like it's
because i swapped
tab count and space tab count should be
subtracted from space count so i'm going
to fix that right now
save and rerun this to verify that it
was fixed
okay my application is running so if i
reload the page
great it looks like it's not negative
anymore and it's showing us the right
number so this looks good
cloud code just helped me debug my cloud
run application locally
using all the normal debugging tools
that i would with intellij without
requiring me to go through a complicated
configuration setup
at this point i feel comfortable
deploying my app to cloud run on gcp
so cloud code lets me do that by using
its deploy run configuration
this time i'm using the cloud code cloud
run deploy run configuration
here i've gone ahead and set that up
i've selected the gcp project that i'm
going to deploy this to
next i configured the deployment
platform and
i can choose between fully managed and
cloud run for anthos
fully managed will have gcp manage all
the infrastructure for me
whereas cloud run for anthos will let me
run my cloud run application on a gke
cluster for example
i'm going to stick with fully managed
and i'm going to deploy this to the u.s
west 1 region here the service name
is what my cloud run app is called so
i've named it vote
and next i configure the authentication
settings
i can either have this allow
unauthenticated invocations
or require authentication and since i
want this to be a publicly available
service i opted for allowing
unauthenticated invocations
this field configures where the
container images i'm building get stored
so i'm going to stick with google
container registry which is the default
here
i also filled out these environment
variables that i did for the local run
run configuration
and last i configured the builder
settings to build my container using
docker
so now if i hit run on the cloud code
cloud run
deploy run configuration it's going to
build my app
containerize it and deploy it to cloud
run on gcp
great so it looks like my application
finished deploying
if i click on the link that it printed
out for me it looks like it deployed
successfully
and i can still cast votes
so to recap cloud code just helped me
iterate on my application
debug it and finally deploy it back to
cloud run
thank you very much matt that was a
great demo
i love tabs versus pieces so let's
summarize
what we've learned today in this talk
we've seen
what cloud run is how it makes it super
easy to run stateless containers in the
cloud
then matt explained what cloud code is
how it sits
inside vs code or intellij as a free
plugin
and makes cloud-native development easy
we created a sample application in vs
screw using cloud code
and then i deployed it to cloud run from
the ide
finally matt showed you how to develop
and debug
a more complex application using
intellij's class good local emulator for
flow drop cloud run
and deployed it to cloudground thank you
very much for your attention
i hope you enjoyed it
you